what is going on there reject nation we are
going to watch today from our friend paul over
at heavy spoilers stranger things season four
ending theories the hidden twist explained in
season five predictions talked extensively
with paul about this show so i'm excited
to see what his video entails proud of the man
he's been killing it lately if you guys leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated if you have
not seen our stranger things season 4 volume 2
reactions you can go check them out they're here
on the channel right now let's get into action
so stranger things 4 volume 2 takes things to
the max with a big ending that sees several
characters dying includes dr brenner eddie and
max who dies during the battle with beckner
max though she's brought back max is left a little
worse for wear and come the conclusion she's in an
unresponsive coma it's a big ending and the finale
sees max using herself as bait in order to draw
beckner out so that steve nancy and robin can go
to his body and burn him whilst he's distracted
this works really well with them getting the
drop on him whilst he's fighting 11 and max
is is henry like impervious to fire it
wasn't exactly like a burning when when
11 sent him into the upside down but it
was like a burning i mean look at him
and now he's just still still roaming no yeah
he's just so much scar tissue now that in order
to actually burn him alive you have to throw
him in like a real volcano or something ooh
mustafar unfortunately though he gets most of the
way through his ritualistic murder and he not only
blinds max but he also breaks several of her bones
killing her in the process eleven reaches out to
her mind and she manages to revive her but it is
possible that she should have let her city sink
into the void using naked memories she pulls
her back from the brink but she may be harboring
something much worse in vechna now throughout
this video we're going to be going through
our theories on what's going on with her how
wekner may be alive and who his next victim is
max theory time i gotta get a theory
time now the final 15 minutes of volume 2
has 11 not only visiting max in hospital but she
also attempts to reach out to her through the void
we find max in an unresponsive coma and
nurselle tries to get through to her on
the psychic plane to see if she can pull her
back that way however her mind is completely
devoid of any life or signs that max is there
and this could be because she's technically
brain dead this is also reflected in what
lucas says too do they know when she awake no
they say she might not her heart stopped
for over a minute she died i mean clinically
then she came back doctors don't know how they
say it's a miracle now clinically she died and
came back but her consciousness didn't because of
this she's now an empty vessel and it is possible
that vecna also now exists in her mind using her
as a way to continue living in the season finale
of when steve and the gang went to check to see if
his body was there he'd got out of it like nancy
did her relationship when sexy steve smiled at her
although he was destroyed in this physical sense
will confirms that he's still out there and we see
this reflected in the environment not only is the
doorway to hell starting to bleed the upside down
into hawkins but there also exists a black cloud
off in the distance that slightly resembles the
mind player okay so wait a minute so this theory
that paul is presenting right here is that vecna
lives within max's mind now somehow or or at the
very least this could open a portal for him to
do as such yeah i've heard uh another theory
going around i think someone commented on our
temperature there's a comment about it reflecting
on paul's channel too fekna says he absorbs people
that he may have absorbed max max's consciousness
was absorbed by vechna so it actually resides
with vechna now versus the opposite like it's
kind of an inverse of what i think paul's actually
suggesting i feel like that would be more likely
given everything that happened it would make more
sense that he would absorb her essence or her
spirit somehow yeah that was like yeah her body is
definitely brain dead however her consciousness is
actually still with vecna maybe somehow in season
five you know like when countering vecna through
mind [__] somehow max will come in and help
save the day maybe not actually come back to
her body and get to live but still get to be
a hero in her own right maybe it will be like
a freddy krueger thing where it's like spirits
trapped within than rebel or something like that
as a child young creel used to be fascinated
with spiders and he drew the shape that would
go on to terrorize hawkins this was clearly how
he viewed himself as being and upon going to the
upside down he said the following i saw a means
to realize my potential to transcend my human form
to become the predator i was always born it
makes sense that if his physical body was to be
destroyed that he'd then take on something that
looked more like the mind flayer for his final
form however i don't think that he's this cloud
per se it's more there just as a warning of what's
to come now i believe that vaccinate is licking
his wounds and he's hiding out of max recovering
along with her the seriousness is so creepy how
this is possible at several points obviously
there is of course will their character was
infected with shadow particles and this created
a symbiosis between him and vechna that he still
feels to this day he didn't fully take over the
character but he was very much a parasite within
him similar to what i believe he's doing with max
there's also the fact that max's mind was used as
a battleground between him and eleven it's a bit
confusing as to how it all plays out but basically
max goes to the creel house and then she draws out
wekner who from his hiding place then psychically
enters her mind using a little nina and the boys
11 is then able to project herself out there so
that the pair can battle it out in max's brain
what i'm really hoping for and i'm sure a lot of
you guys are hoping for too that somehow with the
fact that will has maintained being connected
to the upside down or or vector perhaps in the
season five finale somehow will is able to use
this torture this trauma that he has just been
living with morning noon and night and be able
to become a hero in some way you know i saw this
like interesting tick tock going around that was
showing that how vecna might actually still have
might have really truly been planted since season
one the first time will was taken it was taken the
first time will was taken the bell chime did
go off that resembles vector that could have
been the duffer brothers just being like hey this
bill trump let's kind of use it to our advantage
or it could have been intentional since the very
first season hey maybe by season five will will
have awakened you know extra kinetic powers or
something like that maybe all this exposure to the
upside down will somehow bring him closer to 11
inability that would be amazing now having access
to this due to being one of his victims means that
wekner can technically come and go as he pleases
throughout the first volume he watched as those
he stalked ended up seeing vivid visions of him
before he eventually launched his final attack
during the time between this he'd retreat back
to his body but if he no longer had this to go
back to he'd likely have to hide out in max i
believe that he's actually somewhat feeding
off eleven though she might be completely
unaware of it in the final few scenes we
see eleven spinning a coca-cola bottle and
in between it we get flashes of her time at max's
bedside when she reached into her mind coca-cola
has been something that's popped up throughout
the series and at several points this infamous
string has been used to show 11's abilities i
think the way that this editor is carried out
and the order of the scenes could hint towards
what's going on and why beckner is using her
for example we get the coca-cola scene a quick cut
to 11 reaching out to max hopper's return and then
the dark cloud coming in the way the sequence is
set up makes it seem like it's all connected now
an abusing 11 is a way to power himself up due
to their ties for example love is something
that definitely empowers 11 and having hopper
and joyce's return could have added the slight
boost that wekner needed to then push the upside
down out the chill that will gets on the back of
his neck comes immediately after this and though i
might be reaching i might it does seem like these
moments are played out like this for a specific
reason all of it's very specific as we've come to
learn i do love the idea that because this whole
thing with vecna becoming more powerful as this
absorption machine i do believe that in some way
he does need 11 to be at like maximum power so
that way he can use her abilities like he might
not be strong enough individually but if he can
take the powers of 11 then he'd be unstoppable and
that'd be kind of like a crazier like reveal upon
reveal this whole time he that's why he's never
just gone out and just killed 11 directly but has
been trying to take her oh so he can like complete
himself and like ascend to some kind of other
world it'll be like superman and lois merge with
your bizarro self eleven in the upside down world
now max being lost in the void could also come
back around and potentially she may be the key
to stopping wekner as well bringing her back from
the brink and having the pair fight it out in her
mind for who gets control over her body would be
a big battle and something that could end up being
the way that the series progresses i can actually
see eleven possibly venturing back into max's mind
and she'll start to explore the darkness within it
until she comes across wekner who will have max's
hostage but it's my mind not his right so i should
be able to control where i am i just need to
push him away the pair might potentially fight it
out there and 11 could end up winning which would
free max and allow her to come back this might
then lead wagner into going off into another one
of his potential puppets aka will will early on oh
my god massive ties to the upside down and though
max took a lot of focus in the fourth season when
we're talking human characters that beckner has
his sights on he'd definitely be higher up
than her because he can still feel beckner
i think that he'd be another possible
vessel that he could end up playing into
this is also hindered if we look at the origins of
the name wagner which we of course know comes from
dungeons and dragons this powerful wizard has
several abilities that also include possession
explaining how he could potentially take over the
future characters i don't know there's something
about me that morbidly likes the idea of
will suffering more just bringing it back
to him just under this control i don't know why it
just sounds amusing to me after all this time it's
just like god damn this show just loves to beat
this kid up so much i think it would make it feel
like there is a design to will's overall suffering
because after a while it does start to feel like
ah what do we do with will i don't know let's just
make him suffer in silence so like to have him
then be imbued with vecna and have to go up
against eleven would be heart crunching yeah
i'd be the worst there's also the fact that
we know shadow particles exist out in russia
and he may end up attempting to get access to them
though murray bust out the flamethrower to take
out some demagogue or gas i don't believe that
the shadow particles themselves were destroyed
and we lingered on them long enough for me to
believe that they'll be brought back in some form
or another now it's a long trip for them to fly to
hawkins so this might have just been used as a way
to explain the shadow particles before we learned
that wekner manipulated them in order to attack
hawkins so this could have just been a way to hint
to the final reveal before we got it but let me
know below exactly what you think now i think that
the other members are becoming vectors victims and
that once he's back to full power he'll find
a way to hunt the heroes of hawkins once more
who he's after is anyone's guess but dustin does
fit the profile of one of the people he'd target
through max we discover that those he goes after
tend to have faced some form of trauma and they
harbor feelings of guilt that make them easy to
manipulate this could be seen in destin who could
end up oh my god no over the fact that eddie died
to save him this was of course also murdered in
max who felt like she was personally responsible
for billy's passing dustin could share this too as
that he was getting away but he turned around to
face the bats out of hell which left him gone when
the morning come you know what i honestly would
prefer if he's gonna choose a victim i prefer
it to be joyce i think joyce is the one who's had
so much guilt to deal with and her character has
not been feeling like the most essential i don't
wanna say she's non-essential it's just you know
she she was like the star of the first season
and now she's just kind of like this amusing
supporting character who's just kind of funny once
in a while but really he's not giving that much
weight anymore and i think to do from your season
one to season five to really bring it full circle
imagine her dealing with the amount of guilt and
loss that she's had to deal with over the course
these last four seasons and how much that weight
would uh take a toll on her especially now that
she's back in hawkins herself well that would get
a nice sort of change up in the in just the motifs
too because i feel like so much of the kid's stuff
sort of kept with the kids and isolated so then to
have that boundary crossed of like oh crap we're
facing yeah you know in this in this perverse
form one of our most beloved and close familial
characters i think would be a nice twist on things
and it would actually give hopper an opportunity
it would make that season five personal for hopper
now too especially if it's joyce's life that's
the one being endangered or threatened by vechna
a opportunity it really makes me wonder if they'll
actually kill some of the core cast members next
season as currently seems like they're playing it
slightly safe when it comes to those they murder
sure eddie was a big death but he and jason feel
like they were created just for the season so that
they could be killed off now that brenner is dead
i also hope that dr owens comes back as well to
someone and take care to the next level the next
the 12. you suck now he's also a character that
we don't really know what happened to and it's
unlikely that the military will still trust him
he did however plead with the army to bring ellen
alive and perhaps after seeing the chopper downed
they'll realize that trying to assassinate her
isn't the best way to go about it not really
connected to the original theory on this video
but i thought i'd just throw it in there so
you get a bit of extra bang for your buck on the
video and you bloody did didn't you yeah i'm too
bloody good to you but what i'd love to hear are
your thoughts on what's going on i do think that
if the 11 died some type of ultimate sacrifice
it would also bring it full circle i remember
the duffer brothers saying that they did intention
originally intend to kill off 11 uh but you know
she's too too much of a commodity executive
producers came in and said hey hey hold on a
second this is way too popular of a character yeah
she's great but i think especially if you're gonna
put a final stamp like we are declaring this is
the final season for sure i think killing off
11 would be heartbreaking and devastating but
it kind of seems like it's destined for that
path too it could be very very meaningful i know
there's probably a lot of different ways that the
series could go so make sure you comment below
and let me know for this one big time anytime
all right well thanks for that video paul that was
really well done just certainly sparked the mind
now we just gotta wait like four more years for
season five to come out and we're gonna be rock
and roll and from here on out but guys what do
you think about these did what are your craziest
theories for stranger things five or the ending
of stranger things four leave them down below you
can subscribe to the heavy spoilers channel please
do so help get this gato a million he deserves it
also subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell last but not least let's do a
brian perry got a message from you saying that
you were pledged for this tier for may and june
and that you didn't get a shout out i'm sorry
about that i mean we have like a list here of
everyone that's pledged on patreon automatically
does it your name wasn't there i blame john plain
and simple my fault i think john should have been
able to properly determine this and gone through
every single one of our patrons individually
to make sure you specifically brian did not get
[__] over in the end but you got combed over by
us i'm so sorry brian perry i gotta say though as
someone who didn't actually get the shout out
that you actually still stuck around with us
regardless of you not getting the tier that was
properly they're supposed to be properly delivered
to you not too many people do that usually you
know you get some type of i want to refund i'm
mad at you for not doing this give me my money
back you didn't do that instead you stayed
pledged now we need more people like brian perry
here who go i pay for something i didn't get it
but i'm still gonna keep paying for it i'm not
one of those people how many patreon pages i've
complained to oh my god i lost count brian you're
one of the good ones out there you got a heart of
gold where money's not everything and yet you
still stayed pledged you're a patient cat bro
a lot of character you were the first person
we were shouting out in the month of july
love you brian thank you for being you i better
not see a patreon refund request coming in now